bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
l'actualité ce soir c'est le discours de
Vladimir Poutine à Moscou un discours
antioxydant glorifiant la Grande Russie
historique le chef du Kremlin a voulu
faire de cette journée officielle
d'annexion des quatre provinces
ukrainiennes un jour de fête célébration
en grande pompe sur la place rouge mais
illusion de victoire sur le terrain
l'armée russe recule face au soldats
ukrainien on va revenir dans le détail
sur ce discours combien de temps Poutine
peut-il donner le change grand
décryptage sur ce plateau dans un
instant sommes-nous devenus des animaux
numériques notre grand témoin ce soir
explore en profondeur l'emprise du monde
virtuel sur nos vies et ce n'est pas un
changement de société dans lequel on est
entré mais un changement de civilisation
l'économiste Daniel Cohen signe au mot
numérique US chez Albin Michel il est
notre invité ce soir enfin deux
affranchis deux parties pris ce soir
Matthieu aux anneaux du shift project
nous dira pourquoi planification
écologique est évidemment associée à la
sobriété à quelques jours de l'annonce
du grand plan sobriété du gouvernement
et puis le mot de la semaine de notre
sémiologue Mariette Darrigrand ce soir
fait concertation voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
illusion de victoire simulacre de
démocratie Vladimir Poutine a tout fait
pour sacraliser en grande pompe
l'annexion des quatre provinces
ukrainiennes on va revenir sur son
discours et ses célébrations sur la
Place Rouge avec vous ce soir général
trincam bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ancien chef de la mission
militaire française auprès de l'ONU
bonsoir à la Zara lazareva et bienvenue
sur ce plateau journaliste ukrainienne
vous êtes la correspondante à Paris de
l'hebdomadaire de ukrainienne week
bonsoir nadeza écoutez pova et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes réfugiés
politiques russe en France vous êtes
avocate défenseur des droits de l'homme
vous êtes aussi à la tête d'une ONG qui
protège les victimes d'accidents
nucléaires en Russie et vous avez vous
avez quitté votre pays en 2015 après des
intimidations du régime Patrick Martin
Genier va nous rejoindre dans un instant
vous le connaissez il enseigne à
Sciences Po il est spécialiste des
questions europ européenne le temps
d'abord
pour Stéphane Blacko ski de nous
résumait ce long discours devant une
élite lumineuse du Kremlin il était
assez volumineux mais pas tant que ça
non plus qu'est-ce qu'il a dit Vladimir
Poutine si j'ai bien compris c'est à
vous tout de suite
compris Myriam aujourd'hui c'était la
fête à Moscou il y avait des scènes des
concerts des spectacles des gens dans la
rue et pourtant en ce moment les Russes
n'ont pas vraiment de quoi se réjouir
moi je suis comme tout le monde je suis
les événements à la radio je vois que
sur le front les Ukrainiens progressent
on fait reculer l'armée russe et puis
même en Russie il y a une mobilisation
partielle qui a été déclarée qui s'est
plutôt mal passé on a vu des russes les
plus aisées qui cherchaient à fuir et
même et ça c'était inédit Poutine a
reconnu une erreur dans l'organisation
qui se passait assez mal de de cette
mobilisation alors pourquoi une fête une
célébration en grande pompe en grande
pompe si tout va mal en Russie
c'est justement ça l'astuce si on
organise une grande fête c'est pour
faire croire que tout va bien puisque
les gens sont dans la rue ils s'amuse
mais en même temps c'est vrai que
Poutine a pas besoin de rétablir sa
réputation même au sein de l'opinion
russe parce que il y a aussi des
sondages en Russie sans doute moins
qu'en France et ses sondages disent que
la popular éviter de Poutine est en
baisse alors je voudrais enfin je vous
rassure je vous signale que la grogne
n'est pas non plus monumentale il est
passé de j'ai noté les chiffres 86 je
crois 81 ouais 77% de bonnes opinions
dans un institut indépendant mais donc
c'est quand même un recul et comme
l'image de Poutine auprès de la
population repose sur son image d'homme
fort implacable et bien une victoire
militaire c'est l'occasion voilà
justement de redorer son image et son
blason alors la victoire revendiquée par
Poutine c'est l'annexion de ces de ces
quatre provinces ukrainiennes alors là
on y coupe pas les cartes évidemment on
est obligé de montrer un petit peu des
cartes donc vous voyez les les quatre
provinces qui sont à l'est du crâne donc
Louane ce que donnait ce qu'au nord ça
ce sont c'est le don de base donc c'est
une guerre ou des séparatistes pour
soutenus par Moscou sont conflit en
guerre avec les Ukrainiens depuis
maintenant 8 ans donc c'est un compliqué
qui a duré depuis longtemps plus les
deux provinces plus au sud japonais et
Carson qui elles ont été envahi
récemment et donc voilà c'est cette zone
là que Poutine veut annexer donc ça
correspond à kilomètres carrés on l'a
dit c'est 20% je crois du territoire de
l'Ukraine et donc pour faire le
parallèle avec la France c'est un peu
comme si les hauts de France et la
région Grand Est finalement
disparaissait de notre territoire alors
pour proclamer sa victoire Poutine a
soigné la mise en scène il y avait
beaucoup d'images aujourd'hui à Moscou
est un grand spectacle on avait choisi
je pense que c'est la plus belle salle
du cramé en tout cas était vraiment
magnifique mais j'estueuse et puis c'est
vrai que ça rond avec l'idée qu'on a
souvent vu Poutine seul face au micro
l'homme qui dirige tout et là au
contraire il avait rassemblé dans la
salle tout ce que la Russie compte de
notable au niveau des régions au niveau
de l'administration de l'armée sans
doute pour donner l'image qui n'était
pas seule justement qui avait un pays
entier derrière lui et donc voilà il a
fait cette annonce en s'appuyant sur les
référendums truqués évidemment de cette
décision d'annexion on écoute
je voudrais dire à tous les citoyens qui
habitent dans les régions de luganx
Donetsk à kersen et zapporodia qu'ils
deviennent nos citoyens pour toujours
[Applaudissements]
public discipliné mais bon c'est un
petit peu normal de les circonstances se
passer maintenant quelles vont être les
conséquences de ces annexes
évidemment mais bon moi de ce que je
comprends c'est que en ce moment même
dans ces provinces à NEXY il y a des
soldats Ukrainiens qui combattent les
troupes russes donc dès lors que
Vladimir Poutine dit ses provinces
maintenant elles sont russes c'est la
Russie et bien il peut reprocher aux
Ukrainiens d'attaquer la Russie entamer
une guerre contre la Russie évidemment
on a tous en tête l'idée d'escalade
majeure que on pourrait avoir une frappe
nucléaire russe bon en même temps ça
fait quand même sept fois que Poutine
brandit cette menace nucléaire alors il
dit pas nucléaire là il a dit on se
défend on défendra les provinces par
tous les moyens possibles enfin bon il
l'a répété tellement de fois quand on
sait pas si on doit s'affoler vraiment
et dans son discours ce qui frappait
aussi c'est qu'il ne s'adressait pas
Corus il s'en est prêt aux Occidentaux
et peut-être s'adresser au monde
exactement on a cru au départ que
c'était surtout pour la population russe
puis sous je dirais presque trois quarts
du discours on a vraiment eu le
sentiment en moins la moitié qui
s'adressait au monde notamment quand il
a dénoncé mais sans relâche
l'impérialisme de l'Occident en
s'appuyant sur des faits réel c'est que
l'Europe a colonisé je veux dire
quasiment toute la planète et que les
Américains plus récemment ont mené des
guerres là aussi à peu près dans le
monde entier donc tout ça est vrai mais
il a retourné ce cette fait pour dire
que la Russie elle ne voulait surtout
pas subir le même sort ne voulait
surtout pas être colonisé voilà ça ça
défense
les Occidentaux ne veulent pas nous voir
libres ils souhaitent nous transformer
en colonie
les élites occidentales ont été et sont
toujours des colonisateurs des
colonisateurs qui divisent les peuples
les discriminent nous nous n'avons
jamais mené et ne mèneront jamais de
telles politiques nationalistes et
racistes donc là on sent qu'il s'adresse
parce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les pays
non alignés donc d'autres continents
l'Afrique même en Asie ou en Amérique du
Sud mais il sait aussi adressé
directement ou indirectement aux
populations
occidentales on comprenait bien quand il
a dit ce petit message que je voudrais
écouter que c'est aux Français entre
autres qui s'adressaient
on ne peut pas nourrir les gens avec des
dollars
sociaux ne pourra pas permettre aux gens
de se chauffer et ce que je dis se fait
là est important c'est la réalité
il
soulignait le fait que dès qu'on
critiquait les régimes en place son
Occident on passait pour un extrémiste
et donc manifestement on va parler des
situations militaires mais on sent bien
que dans la technique de Poutine et
aussi une volonté d'alimenter le
populisme en Occident et justement
d'affaiblir la démocratie par ce moyen
merci beaucoup Stéphane pour ce pour ce
résumé Nadia écouter pour voir je vais
commencer par vous vous êtes une Russe
en France qui regardait un président que
vous détestez est-ce que ce discours là
peut remobiliser les Russes ou au
contraire
à l'heure où voilà la mobilisation c'est
choque le pays il n'aurait pas d'effet
vous savez que son discours était
suffisamment longue pour que j'ai perdu
au fond de discours le début
tout d'abord ça me rassemblait en cours
d'histoire par les yeux de régime de
Poutine après ça me rassemblait beaucoup
science de psychothérapie et finalement
j'ai perdu le fil de ton il s'agit de
quoi de ce discours ça veut dire que
chacun qui vit par exemple le moitié de
son discours ne comprend pas il s'agit
de quoi
et ce que je sentais tout d'abord
c'était grand honte pour cette situation
parce que je suis une fille de l'époque
de gorbachov où on a découvert la Russie
normale pour le monde entier ou on a
essayé faire que la Russie nominace au
cou aucune pays du monde on a pris le
chemin de démocratie et maintenant je
peux constater toutes les perdus et tout
est falsifié et tout est imité que vous
avez honte oui
j'ai un honte parce que je le sens comme
en échec personnel je travaillais en
tant que juriste de droite de l'homme
pendant 15 ans dans une petite ville
fermée pour accompagner des victimes
nucléaires et victimes corriger qui on a
gagné beaucoup d'écart et je peux vous
dire que j'ai gagné plus 70ka dans des
tribunaux nationaux à la Cour européenne
de droite de l'homme ça veut dire
c'était possible mais après c'était
totalement révolue en Russie oui c'est
totalement coupé et maintenant vous
savez que cette fête à Moscou je le vois
un peu comme une moquerie
et pour moi ces deux phrases qui tombent
dans mon esprit le premier phrase on dit
en Russie la fête pendant la peste la
fête sur les hausses décadavres de
victimes de cette guerre et deuxième
chose qu'il y a dans mon esprit qui sème
le
la tempête ça veut dire que la réaction
qui on va avoir les victimes qui ont
encore avoir réussi ce serait quelque
chose terrible mais même aujourd'hui je
vois que la Russie a perdu 30 ans de
toute chemin pendant lequel on a essayé
faire notre pays démocratique merci
c'est important d'entendre les voix
russe qui sont voilà en France mais il y
a aussi des Russes qui se dressent qui
essayent de stresser contre Poutine on
les entend pas forcément parce qu'ils
sont pas si nombreux que ça Allah les
Areva bon qu'est-ce qu'on ressent quand
on a ukrainienne au-delà de la
journaliste que vous êtes il y a quatre
provinces annexées on a compris avec
Stéphane l'ampleur du territoire c'est
un pont entier du pays qui est
autoproclamé par le président Poutine
aujourd'hui russe déjà c'est pas
vraiment autoproclamé c'est proclamé par
Poutine
c'est provinces se bat pour donc il y a
une demande de résistance populaire il y
a les partisanes il y a les maquis on
peut dire qui font leur travail il y a
l'armée ukrainienne qui avance donc je
pense que vous allez parler de ça et moi
je suis confiante je pense que quoi
qu'ils disent tôt ou tard il va soit
mourir soit être renversé soit être tu
es je ne sais pas ce que vous avez pensé
du discours vous connaissez aussi les
Russes vous pensez que c'est naturel
aller galvaniser à nouveau que de
s'adresser comme ça en glorifiant la
Grande Russie historique qui elle
n'aurait pas été
coloniale contre l'Amérique contre
l'Occident je vais le sentiment de
revenir dans les périodes de mon enfance
dans les périodes de Brejnev et je me
dis que voilà que on est la Russie n'a
pas aller en avant mais revient en
arrière au lieu de progresser et les
régresses et que ce discours il
ressemble énormément au discours
soviétique justement quand j'étais
j'étais obligé d'être donc
et lire tous ces profs d'Arabes dans
lequel il y avait pas de vérité et la
vérité il veut pas de promenade donc
tous ces médias soviétiques et c'est
voilà c'est très soviétique c'est très
disons c'est l'erreur renversement des
rôles en permanence en fait on fait une
chose on accuse son adversaire de faire
cette chose et en cas d'arme politique
c'est quelque chose de sans doute que
j'hébiste aussi c'est la culture que je
vise de Monsieur petit je crois la
culture cagibi de Monsieur Poutine vous
allez nous dire d'ailleurs ce qui va se
passer maintenant dans les dans les
provinces en question elles vont être
rucides on imagine le rouble le russe va
devenir en fait
allez-y je vous écoute oui donc c'est ce
qu'on sait déjà des territoires occupés
c'est que justement il me pose les
programmes scolaires russes ils retirent
les manuels Ukrainiens il annule même
les cours de la langue craignant il
essaye effacer vraiment toute présence
de tout ce qui est l'identité
ukrainiennes mais je ne pense pas qu'ils
vont arriver général quand vous l'avez
écouté attentivement le président russe
c'est un discours sur la civilisation
finalement qu'il a fait bon l'annexion
passée assez rapidement finalement et
l'annexion de quoi de zone qui sont pour
partie encore sous administration
ukrainienne il faut le rappeler il n'y a
qu'une partie qui est occupée ensuite la
zone bouge en permanence puisque dans la
région de Lima en particulier les
Ukrainiens continuent à avancer donc
mais on passe rapidement là dessus il
fallait dire victoire à un moment donné
et je crois le sujet c'est la suite
c'est à dire le combat continue si j'ose
reprendre des des expressions que nous
avons connues à un certain temps ici le
combat continue et le combat il est
civilisationnel il est sur les valeurs
et là
c'est la guerre que avoir réussi va
mener contre cet Occident pourri bon je
passe tous les termes qui ont été
employés et ça c'est aussi pour toucher
nos sociétés j'ai trouvé très marquant
qu'il emploie des termes qui sont
employés par nos sociétés parents 1 par
en deux il a pas inventé il a dit et
donc je trouve que il veut aussi porter
le fer dans nos sociétés on va revenir
sur ce qui se passe sur le terrain parce
que vous l'avez très bien expliqué
l'armée ukrainienne elle avance et et
les soldats russes reculent dans ses
provinces annexées par par le président
par le président russe Patrick Martin
Genier vous l'avez écouté également ce
discours c'est frappant de voir à quel
point il s'adressait presque plus au
monde
chorus il essaye de faire quoi de créer
une sorte de nouveau face à face de
l'ordre mondial entre quoi les la Chine
la Russie l'Afrique d'un côté et
l'Occident de l'autre oui je crois que
vous l'avez dit je crois d'abord qu'il
veut organiser une sorte de choc
civilisationnel on l'a bien vu dans son
discours qui est un discours finalement
raciste homophobe un discours j'allais
dire fasciste très clairement c'est la
haine de l'Occident c'est ça qui est
frappant et quand vous le dites
effectivement par rapport à l'Ukraine
finalement l'Ukraine s'est subsidiaire
c'est un cas pratique et donc bien
évidemment que c'est une opposition
vis-à-vis de l'Occident de ces valeurs
démocratiques de tolérance et de
démocratie ces gens là ont en haine la
démocratie premièrement deuxièmement il
veut effectivement s'exprimer vis-à-vis
du monde entier vis-à-vis de ses alliés
la Chine d'autres pays Corée du Nord
l'Inde a quand même été plutôt du côté
de la Russie et il s'aperçoit bien
peut-être que ça ne passe pas toujours
l'un de Premier ministre indien a dit
récemment que l'heure était à la paix la
Chine n'emboîte pas systématiquement le
pas maintenant à la Russie donc il voit
bien qu'il pourrait y avoir quelques
difficultés de ce côté-là donc bien
évidemment il veut organiser un monde
multipolaire différents pôles de
puissance la Russie la Chine et avec ses
aînés il veut montrer en réalité que sur
le plan de nos valeurs nous sommes
minoritaires dans le monde il y avait la
volonté aussi de calquer cette cérémonie
sur celle de 2014 même si l'atmosphère
donc l'annexion de la Crimée était très
différente forcément sur le terrain on
va voir déjà les quatre régions la carte
des quatre régions annexée par par
Poutine donc lougans que le done que
personne n'a pas déjà
il faut vous nous disiez sur ces quatre
provinces c'est ces frontières là qui
qui sont qui sont considérés comme
maintenant russe ou juste les positions
russes dans ces territoires
il parle des quatre provinces maintenant
les quatre provinces sont soit sous
occupation russe soit sous
administration ukrainienne pour les
quatre
Kerson zapporijah c'est très clair
donnait également et Louhans c'est là où
actuellement les Ukrainiens sont en
train d'avancer
dans cette province du Nord dans
lesquelles les Ukrainiens résistent et
même une contre-offensive avance les
Ukrainiens progressent donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui lorsqu'il parle de
ses provinces il se garde bien de mettre
une carte devant les yeux des Russes
hein parce que là ça pourrait être
contesté ça c'est le premier point ça
c'est une ville qui a été reprise oui
qui était encerclé alors on n'a pas tout
à fait l'information si elle est tombée
ou pas mais ça devrait être incessamment
sous peu elle est complètement encerclée
par une offensive au nord et par une
offensive au dessus coupian c'est
également sur le plan militaire c'est
très important parce que c'est la ligne
coupiance Belgorod Belgorod c'est en
Russie c'est la ligne logistique qui
alimente toute cette zone jusqu'à
l'édition et donc si cette ligne
logistique est coupée c'est comme ça que
l'imam va tomber et c'est comme ça
probablement que le prochain objectif
physicien pourrait tomber parce qu'ils
ne seront plus alimentés par la
logistique russe donc ça veut dire que
les
Ukrainiens continuent à progresser c'est
pour ça que quand on dit aujourd'hui si
vous voulez que ça va être le territoire
russe et que vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir frappe nucléaire le machin je
n'y crois pas une seconde parce que à
quel moment au moment où ils ont franchi
le kilomètre 10 le kilomètre 20 ou le
kilomètre 25 il y a aucune règle qui est
fixée là-dedans donc je pense que comme
d'habitude
ukrainien a dit qu'il négocierait jamais
avec Poutine tant qu'il était au pouvoir
et que évidemment ces annexions pour lui
sont totalement des mascarades mais
qu'est-ce que ça peut changer quand même
parce qu'il y a une mobilisation
générale aujourd'hui on sait que les
premiers soldats d'ailleurs souvent on
peut expérimenter russe arrive dans le
don de basse qu'est-ce qui peut se
passer premier point ils ont besoin de
renfort c'est une évidence au passage le
président russe était bien gardé d'en
prendre la responsabilité il a rejeté la
responsabilité sur le ministre de la
défense c'est une proposition du midi de
la défense que j'approuve et on va
lancer la mobilisation deuxième point
très intéressant les télévisions russes
depuis quelques jours n'arrête pas vous
critiquer cette mobilisation
l'été vit en russe si elle dit ça elles
ont l'accord du Kremlin ça veut dire que
d'une certaine façon en interne il va
déjà désigner les fauteurs de troubles
il y avait un présentateur le fameux
présentateur vedette qui disait c'est
voilà ces gars là faut les envoyer au
front tous les fauteurs qui montent mal
la mobilisation donc ça c'est sur le
plan psychologique le président Poutine
a dit qu'il mobilisait il a pris une
mesure partielle comme toujours les
demi-mesures sont des mauvaises mesures
c'est à dire qu'il a voulu faire
plaisir aux nationalistes qui demandent
la mobilisation générale mais il est pas
allé jusqu'à la mobilisation générale et
donc il leur fait plaisir mais pas tant
que ça ils sont pas contents ils
continuent à le critiquer sur le terrain
les Russes on le voit bien beaucoup
refusent cette mobilisation et ça ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
voyez ces soldats qui sont en train
d'être mobilisés vous allez deux
méthodes pour les envoyer au feu vous
les former dans des unités vous leur des
équipements un encadrement et là ça
prend du temps et si vous voulez les
envoyer tout de suite vous les envoyez
individuellement dans des unités pour
combler les trous mais là les gaillards
qui combattent depuis six mois ils
disent mon coco toi tu viens d'arriver
moi j'ai sauvé ma peau pendant 6 mois
maintenant c'est à toi de passer devant
et là ça comme c'est ça qui va poser des
sérieux problèmes à l'intérieur des
unités russes sont extrêmement
difficiles de l'armée russe
incorporés n'a reçu de formation ne va
en recevoir normalement ils ont tous ce
sont des réservistes donc ils ont déjà
fait leur service militaire donc
normalement ils sont un peu formés mais
on avait un exemple que tout le monde
cite d'un soldat qui a été envoyé à
Belgorod qui a fait une journée de
formation et qui a été envoyé sur le
terrain donc s'ils sont tous comme ça ça
va être un peu compliqué sans compter
l'équipement qu'on leur donne qui
semble-t-il ne soit pas du top niveau on
ressort les short et 62 les BNP des
années 70 donc
et puis dans des stocks qui tiennent pas
tellement la route justement on va
essayer de d'avoir un peu plus d'en
savoir un peu plus sur la société russe
parce qu'on on sent quand même qu'il y a
une onde de choc depuis cette annonce de
mobilisation partielle on nous dit
300000 hommes c'est sans doute beaucoup
plus c'est Marco pommier qui compile les
dernières images les dernières vidéos
qui nous parviennent sur cette
mobilisation et la difficulté pour les
rues de l'accepter
un cadre majestueux pour un discours
triomphale une mise en scène qui
rappelle les grandes heures de l'Union
soviétique pour mieux dissimuler les
coulisses d'une guerre épouvantable le
New York Times vient de publier des
enregistrements téléphoniques entre les
soldats russes et leurs proches
plusieurs milliers d'appels datant du
mois de mars quelques semaines après le
début de l'offensive en Ukraine dans les
troupes leur ras-le-bol se fait sentir
Poutine est un imbécile il veut prendre
Kiev mais il n'y a aucun moyen qu'on y
arrive quand je rentre à la maison je
démissionne merde à l'armée manque de
matériel désorganisation et lourde perte
dans ces échanges l'armée de Vladimir
Poutine ne cache pas sa détresse et
confirme la réalité des crimes de guerre
comme abucha
on nous a donné l'ordre de tuer tous les
gens qu'on a croisé j'avais jamais vu
autant de corps de toute ma de
vie c'est vraiment taré pour aider
l'armée sur le front ukrainien Vladimir
Poutine a décrété il y a dix jours une
mobilisation partielle 300 000
réservistes appelés au combat au grand
désespoir de certains de leurs proches
revient en vie s'il te plaît
certains parcs d'autres fuis par
milliers l'annonce de la mobilisation a
déclenché un exode massif vers les
frontières du pays par avion ou par la
route sur ces images on aperçoit des
kilomètres de bouchons en direction de
la Géorgie là-bas le nombre d'arrivées
russes a presque doublé de 5 après de
10000 par jour image similaires au
Kazakhstan j'ai pris l'avion pour Samara
puis j'ai conduit de Samara à la
frontière nous avons fait la queue dans
une file d'attente pour piétons pendant
17 heures et j'ai pris la décision très
rapidement de quitter la Russie vous ne
pouvez pas hésiter ici
les gens ne veulent pas se battre ils
disent nous ne voulons pas tuer et être
tués nous voulons sauver nos familles
les gens courent à cause de ça ils
laissent tout ce qu'ils ont et ils
courent
la semaine dernière la Douma la chambre
basse du parlement russe a renforcé les
sanctions pour désertion jusqu'à 10 ans
de prison pour ceux qui refusent de
combattre
Nadia Kouté
des relais des amis qui nous permettent
de mesurer peut-être l'ampleur de ce
front du refus parce qu'on a envie d'y
croire mais on se rend compte aussi que
voilà les soldats ils partent même s'il
y a des résistances mais écoutez le 21
septembre tous les mondes a été choqué
pour cette mobilisation parce que la
population russe est habituée que il ne
faut pas faire confiance à des annonces
s'il y a le mot partiel ou quelque chose
comme ça ça veut dire en tout cas total
tu vois partielle tu penses que c'est
total deuxième chose qui était au moment
où c'était vraiment une chasse pour les
mobiliser ou les centres militaires et
les chefs militaires attrapaient des
gens dans la rue dans leur endroit de
travail sans aucune critère à remplir où
immédiatement donné des convocations
juste en vérifiant des passeports
et après la société se diviser se
diviser pour ce qui peut partir et ce
qui ne peut pas partir ce qui peut
partir ils sont partis ici partir mais
c'est curistes c'est qui est-ce que ces
gens soutient Poutine ou est-ce qu'ils
ne se tient Poutine est-ce que le
soutient de la guerre est-ce que nous
soutient la guerre tout d'abord la
plupart des gens ne sont pas d'accord à
détertuer pour cette guerre mais il y a
un grand mai dans ce cas là que pendant
toute leur époque pour pendant toute son
époque Poutine a réussi
faire et militariser la conscience des
Russes première chose deuxième chose il
a réussi s'associer la patrie en tant
que la Russie et le régime de lui en
tant que la Russie c'est pourquoi dans
beaucoup des familles entrer en fils et
une maman
vous montrer en
Marie et une femme il y avait des
discussions que je ne veux les femmes
dit que je ne veux pas que tu vas à la
guerre et les hommes répondent mais
écoute je ne veux pas aussi mais comment
je peux refuser je suis patriote de mon
pays je dois y aller pour servir à mon
pays et après si il est prête à parler
il peut la dissuader mais s'ils ne sont
pas prêtes
vous nous décrivez quand même un pays
qui commence à se diviser qui sort de la
pâtie aussi c'est à dire que jusqu'à
présent il y avait une forme de déni
avec cette mobilisation la société russe
au moins
ose discuter elle a toujours peur mais
elle ose discuter vous y croyez vous à
ce choc dans la société russe ou on aime
trop nous-mêmes se dire que ça peut se
passer
en 2014 et donc la guerre a commencé on
voudrait dire il y avait très très peu
de russe qui était contre qui se sont
supprimer de cette façon là il y en
avait un peu mais vraiment pas beaucoup
quand le combat a commencé à Donbass il
y avait très peu qui ont dit que c'est
un taux de prendre les terres qui sont
pas nous on est déjà le pays le plus
grand du monde pourquoi il nous faut
encore plus donc un soleil c'était il y
en avait il y en avait c'est pas une
option on revient pas sur 50 ans
probablement du jour au lendemain quoi
disons que il y a pour moi il y a les
exceptions qui confirmer les règles et
que dans les règles oui je pense que
j'aurais joint l'analyse Nadia Nadia
c'est que effectivement les gens sont
très formatisés très disons le cerveau
sont formatés pardon et que le cerveau
sont trop bien laver effectivement elle
s'associe au régime au lieu de
s'associer à une pays et souvent bon je
peux aussi voir ça par les gens que je
connaissais avant en Russie avec qui
j'ai coupé toutes les relations parce
que c'est absolument insupportable c'est
comme les zombies une possible avoir un
échange et on peut voilà donc c'est
comme les zombies
qui peuvent laisser supposer que ce
régime est fragilisé vous savez les
pires dictatures finissent par tomber
rappelez-vous ciao cescu à la veille il
faisait un discours il était dans son
armée et le lendemain il était
pourchasser il était utilisé par être
fusible pourquoi parce qu'à un moment
donné des dirigeants complètement
irresponsable vous avez montré des
messages ce sont des gens qui mettent en
danger leur propre pays et même dans
l'entourage parfois militaire il se peut
se passer un certain nombre de choses et
je dirais attention on dit bien sûr
aucun soulèvement n'est possible je
n'exclue pas une révolution de palais
rappelez-vous que chef en 1962 la crise
des fusées à Cuba 2 ans après il était
parti donc je pense qu'il y a aussi des
choses
effectivement et donc je pense en effet
que et bien il pourrait y avoir il est
fragilisé il y a eu des députés des
conseillers municipaux de
Saint-Pétersbourg de Moscou il y a des
gens qui ouvertement disent non donc
c'est quand même un signe que même dans
une dictature et bien il y a des choses
qui commencent à bouger
la défaite progressive de l'armée russe
qui n'est pas au bout
tout ceci va se prolonger et va
probablement accentuer les fêlures les
fractures qui a dans le pouvoir de
Poutine je pense pas que la rue le
mettra dehors mais en revanche la
pression de la rue sur l'environnement
de Poutine pourraient avoir un effet
l'environnement se disant oulala on va
perdre le pouvoir il est allé trop loin
et tiens il a une crise cardiaque où il
achète pas quoi bon un truc voilà
pire que lui alors oui mais pardon pire
par lui pour la Russie c'est pas bien
pour la négociation c'est bien parce que
vous pourrez discuter avec quelqu'un
d'autre avec Poutine vous pourrez pas
c'est lui qui a lancé l'affaire donc lui
il est dans sur son couloir de nage là
et vous l'arrêterez pas en revanche un
autre même plus nationaliste dira et si
on veut sauver le pouvoir il faut qu'on
aille négocier et ça sera peut-être plus
facile je pense avec quelqu'un d'autre
alors je voudrais essayer maintenant
d'aller sur les différentes positions de
l'Occident et des grandes démocraties
les États-Unis notamment d'ailleurs qui
ne donne davantage d'argent à un plan de
12 milliards militaires pour le crâne
des sanctions nouvelles après cette
annexion condamnée par l'ensemble des
capitales dans les grandes démocraties
qu'est-ce qui se peut se passer
maintenant déjà sur le nucléaire est-ce
qu'on joue à se faire peur ou est-ce que
maintenant Poutine considère que voilà
il peut y avoir des armes de l'OTAN en
Russie via l'armée ukrainienne non non
je pense que on joue pas à se faire peur
il joue à nous faire peur il utilise la
peur et ça fait partie de la dissuasion
en clair le dialogue nucléaire c'est de
faire tellement peur à l'autre que il va
se freiner et il va pas y aller et là
vous avez raison de souligner qu'elle va
être latitude
une cohésion des Européens et des
Américains à la fois face à la menace
nucléaire mais face aussi à la crise
économique que nous allons connaître et
il faut que cette unité soit bien
marquée les Américains ne lâcheront pas
le crâne pas de toute façon les
américains ils souffrent pas beaucoup
dans l'affaire au contraire il gagne
plutôt avec le gaz avec lavandables avec
tout ça donc il souffre pas trop et le
président Biden a bien dit qu'il y aura
pas un soldat américain sur le sol
ukrainien ceux qui souffle le plus sont
les Européens et les Européens il faut
qu'ils arrivent pour l'instant ils le
montrent bien ils montrent qu'ils sont
unis derrière l'Ukraine donc à mon avis
c'est plutôt l'Europe qui doit
absolument montrer sa cohésion cette
cohésion européenne elle peut tenir
Georgia Meloni a été très clair à la
nouvelle présidente du Conseil italien
elle a condamné les annexes et très
clairement en tout cas sur cette
question là de l'Ukraine en soutien oui
c'est à peu près le seul point sur
laquelle elle est claire mais avec la
difficulté puisque son collègue Matteo
saldini de la Ligue qui est très faible
lui clairement s'est prononcé contre les
sanctions contre la Russie l'extrême
droite en Europe qui commence à prendre
des responsabilités au gouvernement ou
dans les soutiens à des gouvernements et
contre les sanctions pour contre la
Russie à cause de l'Ukraine oui l'Europe
jusqu'à présent a été unie et ça c'est
formidable effectivement elle a montré
qu'elle était capable de se mobiliser
parce que c'est sa survie politique et
pas uniquement économique est en jeu et
on peut dire effectivement
qu'aujourd'hui les ambassadeurs à
Bruxelles étaient en train de négocier à
8e train de sanction avec évidemment des
gens qui ne sont pas solidaires tels que
le premier ministre Orban qui a
clairement dit qu'il s'opposait à toute
nouvelle sanctions en matière
énergétique mais oui on peut dire que
jusqu'à présent heureusement l'Europe a
été très solidaire dans le soutien
économique et militaire à l'Ukraine
et puis aujourd'hui voilà ce qui en a
profité pour
redemander formellement son adhésion à
l'OTAN espoir fait vivre bah disons que
très honnêtement je pense que la
l'architecture des défenses et en Europe
dans le monde sera très différent une
fois que cette guerre sera finie ce sera
le temps ce serait une autre alliance
serait encore troisième chose je ne sais
pas je pense que le crâne va partir
après le nombre de cette structure je
peux pas me le donner je pensais que ça
arrivera je suis sûr que ça arrivera
quand je pense que la réaction immédiate
du président Zelinski c'est de
s'adresser aux présidents politiques en
disant vous voulez la guerre vous avez
la guerre on avait dit qu'on rentre pas
dans le temps vous nous avez poussé dans
nos extrêmes on va entrer dans le temps
maintenant la réalité des choses c'est
que bien sûr il ne rentrera pas dans le
temps immédiatement je rappelle que vous
ne pouvez pas rentrer dans le temps
quand vous êtes un pays en guerre donc
mais la déclaration montre bien de quel
côté se place le président zeninski donc
il y a pas de soucis là-dedans
maintenant effectivement l'architecture
de sécurité on sait qu'il y a des
propositions qui sont en cours
on va voir mais clairement le président
Poutine là n'est pas rentré dans une
possibilité de discussion ou de
négociation donc tout ça on le garde
pour nous pour un avenir plutôt éloigné
peut-être elle a été prochain vous voyez
où l'année prochaine comment vous voyez
la suite moi je vois la suite
aujourd'hui ou
il accélère parce qu'il échoue oui tout
à fait et je c'est un tournant en
particulier pour nous j'étais sur un
autre plateau ce matin où j'étais un peu
le seul à dire voilà ce qui va se passer
il va foncer il va dire la guerre c'est
une guerre de civilisation alors que les
autres pensées qui auraient une
ouverture vers la négociation donc là il
a été clair donc ça veut dire que la
guerre va continuer alors sur le terrain
encore une fois pas de panique avec la
force nucléaire parce que le terrain est
grignoté petit à petit et on sait pas si
on va frapper à 10 ou 20 km et donc je
pense que la guerre va continuer je
pense que l'Ukraine va toujours être
soutenu par les occidentaux dans les le
domaine d'armement même s'il y a des
difficultés effectivement économiques
avec avec l'Europe donc on verra l'été
prochain
[Musique]
écoutez je parle beaucoup avec des
Français et des partisans de Poutine ici
en Europe qui me contredit en disant que
je n'aime pas la Russie et je rappelle
toujours que il faut distan faire la
distance entre Poutine et de la Russie
et moi le peuple russe oui et moi j'aime
la Russie et je ne peux plus et à ce
moment qu'il prononçait ses discours
dans cette endroit magnifique je pense
des pauvres russes qui Risso à petites
retraite qui ne peut acheter que une
butée de lait et une baguette pour une
journée qui ne peut pas faire prendre le
dans leur maison parce que pas
d'économisation esclaves en fait de
cette situation c'est de la question des
minorités qui sont colonisés
c'est histoire donc mais les gens ils
jugent d'aujourd'hui et pour ça pour
toujours sur cette un peu morale on
n'aime pas des Américains on n'aime pas
être danseur mais écoutez il faut
toujours se souvenir tenir ce qui était
le début de ce conflit en 91 Lyon se
vit-il c'est tombé il y avait certains
peuples qui ont signé l'accord on a
partagé ce territoire on a posé les
signatures deuxième fois c'était 94 où
on a signé le papier mais marrante ou à
Budapest ou l'Ukraine a refusé l'armée
nucléaire et la Russie acceptait la
frontière la Crimée c'est à l'Ukraine et
tout c'était à l'Ukraine et aujourd'hui
faire
l'Ukraine c'est formidable et pour
terminer et pour terminer et pour tout
ça tout ce territoire c'est toujours
l'Ukraine
[Musique]
si on vous invite Daniel Cohen c'est
parce que ça va trop vite le numérique
c'est incrusté partout tout le temps Vie
privée vie publique en vie colère désir
des groupes politiques sexe travail à
1000 loisirs amours et on a envie
d'appuyer sur pause et de penser avec
vous ou cela nous mène pour nous aider à
prendre du recul sur notre époque vous
avez le profil idéal président de
l'École d'économie de Paris directeur du
Centre pour la recherche économique vous
savez dresser le portrait de l'homme
dans sa société disant après l'homo
économicus vous nous présentez un homo
numérique US très éloigné de la promesse
initiale du numérique on pensait qu'on
allait rentrer dans dans une
intelligence collective d'un genre
nouveau on voyait des Wikipédia jaillir
au coin de chaque rue et c'est un peu
exactement le contraire qui se produit
on se rend compte à quel point la
révolution numérique au fond des soins
nos attentes qu'au lieu de produire une
intelligence collective et le produit un
monde de postes vérité elle produit de
l'attention de la haine de la
polarisation
[Musique]
radicalisation des opinions déni du réel
montée du populisme abaissement de la
parole politique votre livre déplore les
effets délétères du numérique sur le
débat public mais vous allez plus loin
encore en nous présentant un homo
numérique US toujours plus solitaire on
voit que le capitalisme numérique vise à
éviter le présentiel autant que possible
réduire les interactions humaines au
strict minimum et ça crée évidemment des
pathologies considérables
alors faut-il tout jeter dans ce fameux
capitalisme numérique non bien sûr ce
serait trop simple votre ouvrage salue
aussi les effets positifs des réseaux
notamment dans les mouvements de
contestation me too c'est important
c'est grâce au réseau sociaux les
révolutions arabes c'est important c'est
grâce au réseau sociaux donc s'il y a
une force de protestation c'est évident
et c'est très bien et pour terminer
Daniel Cohen nous avons une femme à vous
présenter
elle s'appelle Taniou elle est virtuelle
mais elle vient d'être nommée PDG d'une
entreprise chinoise elle nous inspire
cette question que nous vous posons ce
soir pouvons-nous encore domestiquer le
numérique où sommes-nous condamnés à
être domestiqués par lui
bonsoir Daniel Cohen bons et merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous j'ai envie de
dire vous êtes autant économiste que
sociologue et même historien dans ce
livre parce que vous puissiez être dans
toutes les disciplines même
l'épistémologie l'histoire des sciences
pour répondre alors à cette question
parce que au fond vous montrez très bien
qu'on s'adapte presque avec délice à ce
monde du numérique qu'on a inaptitude à
s'y glisser aucune résistante n'est
produit
je crois que c'est Lévi Strauss qui
disait qu'il y avait cette formule
l'espèce humaine est la seule qui se
soit domestiquée elle-même donc c'est
extraordinaire et c'est tout à fait ce
qu'on est en train de vivre à nouveau on
voit bien que tous ces protocoles pour
rentrer le code
s'habituer à l'idée qu'il y aura jamais
un humain au fond de nos questions et
que c'est à nous nous débrouiller dans
cette jungle numérique on voit bien que
c'est c'est un travail de domestication
c'est-à-dire qu'on est en train de
former les humains à un monde nouveau le
numérique ou l'idée n'est plus de parler
à quelqu'un mais de parler à des
algorithmes alors dans votre livre
raconte bien d'abord une forme de
désillusion la promesse qui n'est pas au
rendez-vous finalement la révolution
numérique ça devait nous élargir les
possibles nous faire aller vers les
autres et c'est tout le contraire qui se
produit exactement on attendait de la
révolution numérique quelque chose comme
un nouveau Gutenberg il y avait
d'ailleurs un livre qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait comme ça on pensait que le
modèle allait être un peu celui de
Wikipédia c'est-à-dire tout d'un coup
accéder à une intelligence collective
nouvelle et moi-même je dois dire qu'au
départ j'ai cru que la mondialisation
avait trouvé la manière avec les réseaux
sociaux mais plus généralement avec
internet de créer une société civile
mondiale qui allait être en phase avec
ce nouvel espace économique qu'on était
en train de découvrir avec la
mondialisation donc j'étais aussi dans
cette naïveté de penser que ça allait
nous permettre de créer une intelligence
collective une manière de dialoguer à
travers les frontières ce que ça fait
évidemment en partie j'ai moi-même plein
de collègues quatre coins de la planète
avec lesquels j'organise maintenant
régulièrement des zooms qui nous
permettent au fond de travailler d'une
manière qu'on n'aurait jamais pu
imaginer auparavant mais ce qui est
certain c'est que on attendait Gutenberg
on a eu tout à fait autre chose on a un
monde de fake news de post-vérité on a
la gouvernance par le tweet on a quelque
chose qui est en réalité ressemble
davantage à une régression politique qui
a une immensité on cherchait l'autre on
cherchait de l'information de la
connaissance du savoir et du partage et
finalement on vient chercher et c'est ça
l'effet moment que des croyances on est
dans des bulles cognitives entre soi ou
on ne fait que trouver confirmation de
ce qu'on croit déjà exactement on est
dans un monde où l'information qu'on
croyait être universel dont on croyait
qu'elle est de devenir l'aliment au fond
de cette conversation philosophique
planétaire on s'est rendu compte que
l'information est devenue un bien de
consommation exactement quand comme les
autres vous rentrez sur Internet comme
dans un magasin
vous y cherchez des informations qui
vous plaisent exactement aussi simple
que ça donc si vous pensez que je sais
pas quoi la guerre en Ukraine a été
puisque vous en parliez a été provoqué
en réalité par des grands groupes
pétroliers ou gaziers qui vous laisse
enrichir vous cliquez vous allez trouver
un million 10 millions de personnes qui
pensent exactement comme vous et vous
allez très vite vous enfermer dans une
bulle cognitive dans une bulle numérique
tout le contraire de l'intelligence de
la conversation dont on parlait mais
plutôt une logique de secte
d'enfermement dans lequel ce qui soude
les gens qui s'y retrouvent en réalité
c'est à la fois des idées fantasques et
surtout la détestation de tous ceux qui
ne pensent pas exactement comme donc le
contraire de l'humanisme que la
révolution de l'imprimerie avait produit
en Europe à partir du 16e siècle le
livre s'ouvre sur la série géniale
britannique Black Mirror d'ailleurs il y
a plusieurs références dans le livre
raconter nous parce que ça permet de
bien comprendre comment justement on
s'adapte à ces nouvelles technologies
plutôt qu'essayer de de comprendre
[Musique]
elle va se fâcher avec tout le monde on
va lui enlever toutes ces étoiles et
finalement son compte et on voit cette
espèce de servitude volontaire auquel au
fond se soumet pour être accueilli
accepter dans cette société numérique
d'une parenthèse = la fin elle m'a
emprison elle n'a plus d'étoiles elle a
tout perdu et son Condé tenu comment ça
allait dire quelque chose et elle se met
à l'insulter elle parle très fort comme
jamais elle avait parlé on se rend
compte qu'en réalité elle a gagné sa
liberté elle est sortie de ce système de
cette étude sociologique formidable
d'éveil ou sur tinder alors c'est un
autre angle tout à fait bon évidemment
inquiétant de la société numérique au
fond si on économise ce que je suis
aussi et encore on essaie de comprendre
ce que fait la révolution numérique
c'est finalement extrêmement simple
c'est donner des gains de productivité à
la société actuelle qui est une société
de service des gains de productivité
c'est permettre par exemple à un ouvrier
de faire en une heure ce qu'il faisait
auparavant en deux heures et toute la
conception par exemple du travail à la
chaîne a été faite pour créer des gestes
économes qui permettent de visser de
plus en plus vite les choses qui vous
sont présentées dans la société de
services ce sur quoi on essaye de faire
des économies ce pourquoi on essaye de
gagner des gains de productivité ce sont
les relations interpersonnelles voyez on
est là on se parle font il y a une
vitesse naturelle auquel on ne peut pas
échapper et qui est la source du plaisir
que nous avons à nous rencontrer mais
tout est fait pour couper ça pour
réduire ce temps où vous allez dans un
guichet de banque vous allez attendre
qu'on vous prenne vous allez voir un
médecin et vous allez attendre qui vous
soigne tout est fait pour réduire ses
temps de fonctionnement de la société
c'est pas moi qui l'ai pratiqué mais tel
que je l'ai lu dans ce livre d'éveilius
qui s'appelle la fin de l'amour tinder
vise exactement à faire ça vise à
réduire le temps nécessaire pour se
rencontrer donc grâce aux algorithmes de
rencontre vous aller très vite
rencontrer des personnes nouvelles alors
tinder attention en un certain sens
c'est une libération c'est une
émancipation puisque ça va vous
permettre de rencontrer des gens que
vous n'auriez pas rencontré autrement
donc ça vous permet de sortir peut-être
du cadre et vous parlez de la relation
quand même réduite mais le problème
c'est que comme le principe de tinder
c'est de gagner du temps dans la dans la
course dans la cour amoureuse comme en
réalité ça vous promet une infinité de
rencontre en réalité vous ne rencontrez
les gens que très peu très vite just
fuck c'est le mot qu'utilise evaillous
pour caractériser ce qu'il reste de
cette relation amoureuse donc ça n'est
plus du tout une relation amoureuse
c'est le travail à la chaîne où on
produit en chaîne des rencontres en les
vidant en réalité de leur âme justement
le travail à la chaîne c'est ce que vous
montrez dans dans le livre comment le
numérique prolonge la taylorisation des
esprits
d'industrialiser la société poste
industrielle est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer il y a cette idée qu'on n'a
jamais vécu dans l'histoire de
l'humanité une société à la fois
horizontale et laïque vous dites que
c'est inédit oui alors la première chose
c'est que je décris toutes les
pathologies qui naissent cette obsession
d'aller très vite quand on se rend
compte cette manière de penser sur
Internet qui n'est pas du tout une
manière de penser donc tout ça est très
négatif mais à l'origine il y a une
promesse cette promesse je crois qu'on
peut la restituer on va dire aux années
60 à la contre-culture des années 60 qui
a fait entendre une protestation contre
l'ordre vertical patriarcale qui pouvait
exister dans la société dans les
familles dans les universités où le
Mandarina gouvernait les étudiants dans
l'usine évidemment où chacun obéissait
un protocole et il sait toujours un
supérieur hiérarchique cette
protestation la révolution numérique est
pionniers de la révolution numérique
dans les années 70 l'ont utilisé au fond
il rêvait sciemment de créer les moyens
d'un monde horizontal et quand on essaie
de réfléchir à ça on voit que les
sociétés peuvent être de deux types
elles peuvent être horizontales ou
verticales donc ça fait deux
possibilités et elles peuvent être
religieuses ou laïques donc ça fait 4
possibilités on était dans la société
industrielle des années 60 dans une
société verticale de béissance et laïque
parce que c'était les ingénieurs qui
gouvernaient le monde et on avait quitté
deux siècles avant la société agraire
qui était elle-même verticale c'était le
roi qui commandait à ses barons qui
commandaient à ses paysans mais
religieuses parce qu'ils étaient on a
essayé toutes les possibilités sauf
celle-là horizontale
horizontale et laïque on a connu
horizontale et religieux chez les
chasseurs-cueilleurs c'était des
sociétés de petite taille où on font des
hiérarchies étaient très faibles mais
elles étaient habitées par l'idée que
des esprits unifiaient les humains et
les animaux notamment et là on est à la
recherche d'une société d'horizontalité
on se parle je te tutoie je te fait
confiance et la X et il y a pas de
principe d'autorité c'est ça qui se
cherche mais on n'y arrive pas on n'y
arrive pas à cause de toutes les
pathologies dont on a justement c'est
quand même aussi pour arriver dans une
civilisation un peu meilleure ce livre
c'était pas simplement pour
diagnostiquer ce qui va nous tomber
dessus vous allez nous dire quels sont
les moyens au fond de bien de
domestiques et tout ça d'une certaine
façon de garder la relation à l'autre
voilà et la relation au monde mais je
voulais vous montrer une image est-ce
que vous connaissez ce tableau là vous
voyez ce que c'est ou pas alors je vais
vous dire le théâtre d'opéra spatial de
Jason Allen et ce théâtre et bien il a
gagné un concours artistique il y a
personne derrière à part un algorithme
un logiciel d'intelligence artificielle
qui s'appelle midjowney et mi-journée
produit des images on lui donne des
critères et il devient peintre il
devient il fait des tableaux et il gagne
un concours de d'artistes est-ce que les
choses sont réjouir alors il faut
évidemment s'en inquiéter à partir du
moment où on délègue à la la machine des
tâches qu'on faisait auparavant il y a
toujours un moment de dépossession il
faut être sûr qu'on est derrière en
l'occurrence je suis presque sur qu'il y
a un humain qui a vérifié que le tableau
de l'algorithme était bien l'algorithme
produit des possibilités en croisant des
contraintes qu'on lui impose tu me fais
du bac et du Bob Dylan il va vous sortir
un truc qui peut être une cacophonie
totale il s'en rendra pas compte ou qui
peut être une merveille donc il y a
toujours des humains pour vérifier parce
que la machine n'a pas de sensibilité
donc on peut déléguer au fond à la
machine le rôle d'explorer des
possibilités en fait les joueurs de GO
ont découvert que la machine était
capable parce que elle peut faire des
milliards de milliards de parties alors
que les humains ne peuvent en fait que
d'en faire que des milliers a découvert
des stratégies auxquelles les humains
n'avaient jamais pensé c'est c'est sympa
ça va mais le problème il est à mon avis
dans le fait que on a d'un côté un
processus ou l'intelligence artificielle
va prendre une place croissante dans
l'organisation du monde et où nous
pauvres humains au lieu d'en profiter
pour accéder à la sagesse au fond
plaisir de pouvoir dire j'aime pas ça
faire ça etc on est plutôt dans un
processus malheureusement en partie des
bêtises c'est-à-dire que ce que la
machine fait de nous c'est de créer des
machines addictives on scrolle un peu
comme ça comme des imbéciles on est dans
dans un processus on ne peut pas dire
que ce soit notre sagesse qui est flatté
et c'est ça c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
reprendre contre pour reprendre contrôle
non pas individuellement parce que ça
n'arrivera effectivement par des corps
intermédiaires par voilà une éthique
professionnelle voilà vous vous n'allez
pas accepter ceci ou cela au nom du fait
que l'algorithme dit que c'est bien il
faut retrouver peu si le possession
collectivement de ce qui nous arrive et
le problème de la machine c'est je
disais il y a un héritage mai 68 il y a
aussi un héritage libéral et nous
transforme en individu et on pense que
seul on va y arriver ça n'est pas
possible merci beaucoup Daniel
cohenericus la civilisation qui vient
c'est chez Albin Michel vous serez à
Blois ce lundi ce weekend exactement LCP
et partenaire je tenais pas le signaler
du 5 au 9 octobre on aura d'ailleurs un
film documentaire avant la catastrophe
sur l'avènement du parti nazi dans
l'Allemagne des années 30 on aurait
encore beaucoup de questions à vous
poser sur l'importance de l'histoire les
crises dans l'histoire est-ce qu'on les
répète ou pas mais nous serons à Blois
pour vous écouter merci infiniment
Daniel Cohen c'est l'heure à présent
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
partie pris ce soir un nouveau visage
celui de Mathieu aux anneaux du shift
projet pourquoi la planification et la
sobriété vont de pairs à quelques jours
du lancement de l'annonce pardonnez-moi
de du plan sobriété et puis le mot de la
semaine il est signé Mariette darrigan
ce soir c'est concertations vous restez
avec nous nos affranchis les voici
Daniel Cohen vous voulez écouter nous
affranchir vous êtes pressés vous êtes
obligé de partir alors on va vous
laisser on va vous laisser glisser comme
ça très discrètement merci on est en
direct alors bonsoir bonsoir d'abord on
va commencer par vous Mathieu d'abord je
suis ravie de vous accueillir vous êtes
vous êtes l'un des principaux
fondateurs qu'est-ce que je dois dire
pour le chiffre français directeur du
chiffre project on en a beaucoup parlé
ici avec Jean-Marc joncovici vous nous
parlez de planification écologique ce
soir et de sobriété donc quelques jours
le gouvernement va annoncer son plan
sobriété pour les entreprises
principalement mais aussi les
particuliers les deux mots sobriétés
planification vont nécessairement
ensemble c'est ça
de voir que les disons les idées neuves
sont assez rares et là avec l'émergence
ces derniers mois de d'une convergence
de autour de ces mots de planification
et de sobriété on a je crois quelque
chose à la fois très nouveau et très
remarquable et c'est pas juste à cause
de Poutine même si la crainte de pénurie
d'énergie cet hiver a sans doute pas mal
accéléré les choses qu'on a ce duo
sobriété planification qui va ensemble
et il faut comprendre pourquoi
d'abord la sobriété sortir des énergies
fossiles ça suppose de s'organiser pour
faire avec beaucoup moins pourquoi faire
avec beaucoup moins parce que les
énergies fossiles c'est les énergies
faciles pardon pour le jeu de mots mais
ça veut dire que toutes les alternatives
au pétrole au gaz au charbon dont il
faut se débarrasser pour le climat et
puis qui existent sur terre en quantité
finie et puis qui ont une fâcheuse
tendance à être contrôlé par des gens
qui sont pas forcément très sympathiques
ces énergies fossiles leurs alternatives
sont toutes plus chers et plus
compliquées à mettre en oeuvre donc sans
passer ça veut dire faire avec beaucoup
moins
et ça ça implique la planification
voilà du long terme et de savoir
exactement ce qu'on veut faire sur les
30 prochaines années réussir à
s'organiser collectivement de façon
efficace sans se faire la guerre
réussir ce tour de force historique de
se passer complètement de ces énergies
fossiles c'est tout simplement pas
possible si on ne sait pas se être
d'accord sur un sur un plan
et donc parce que vous avez entendu
qu'il a été prononcé par le président de
la République ce mot est pas seulement
d'autres responsables avant lui on a
joué on a joué au chiffre project un
rôle important pour faire émerger cette
notion là donc c'est c'est heureux c'est
une bonne nouvelle de voir que du gauche
à droite des pros nucléaires au pro
renouvelables on se met d'accord
là-dessus et c'est quelque chose qui est
presque une anomalie en politique c'est
que ça découle de constats objectifs on
n'a pas l'habitude de ça en politique
pourquoi parce que ce problème de la
sortie des énergies fossiles
il découle d'un problème qui est
fondament fondamentalement technique et
et ce problème technique et bien il
obéit à des lois objectifs qui sont les
lois de la physique qui sont pas les qui
sont pas les lois humaines on a mis 25
ans pour accepter de faire parler la
nature dans le débat public et on n'a
pas 25 ans pour entendre ce que nous
hurlent les systèmes techniques qu'il
faut faire avec moi il faut un plan pour
ça et que il faut trouver comment
comment est-ce qu'on s'organiser ce que
je vous propose c'est de revenir la
semaine prochaine parce qu'on aura les
annonces vous nous direz cette à la
hauteur de la planification ici le
couple avec la sobriété est au
rendez-vous Mariette concertation
forcément après la décision d'Elizabeth
borne de lancer une nouvelle série un
nouveau cycle de concertation sur les
retraites c'est votre mot de la semaine
oui alors ce qui m'intéresse là-dedans
c'est que le mot est sorti vous savez un
peu comme la fumée blanche quand on élit
le pas du dit déjeuner ou du dîner à
l'Élysée puisque il ne voulait pas dire
grand chose sauf que les tenants du
dialogue avaient gagné sur les tenants
du coup de force enfin du passage en
force donc ce mot il est intéressant
parce qu'il est très nouveau vous allez
voir dans la langue française et là il
était comme un petit chiffon quand le
que l'on agite d'habitude en fait et
c'est on le confond avec on parle de
consultation consultation c'est un beau
mot très noble justement qui reprend
cette idée de d'échanger d'en parler
Daniel Cohen tout à l'heure conversation
consultation bon ça on sait ce que c'est
qu'en montagne parlait avec La Boétie
c'était déjà ça mais avec les retraites
on
ce rendez-vous là alors pourquoi
l'utiliser ça fait des années que l'on
parle quand on pense aux jeunes qui sont
nés en 95 ils ont presque 30 ans
aujourd'hui ils ont moins de 7 ans bon
alors ils sont nés avec ce problème et
cette espèce de consultation permanente
ou concertation c'est tout à fait autre
chose c'est un mot très récent dans la
langue française il est né en 1963 c'est
vraiment étonnant et il vient de la
langue il a été construit par la langue
la langue syndicale parce que 1963 c'est
un moment de d'apogée si de la vie
syndicale il y a des grandes grèves dans
le nord de la France et une bataille
extraordinaire gagnée par les syndicats
et pourquoi parce qu'il faisait
concertation donc ça veut dire en fait
être ensemble et pas du tout le que le
collègue exécutif par avec les corps
intermédiaires si vous voulez bon bah
écoutez on va essayer de savoir comment
il est incarné ce mot puisque on est
parti pour un cycle de concertation mais
si j'ai bien compris la concertation à
la fin c'est le gouvernement qui décide
c'est ça on verra si un musical alors
peut-être que c'est comme concert on va
voir on va voir peut-être un spectacle
merci beaucoup Mariette d'Harry grand
pour ce mauve sous votre loupe de
sémiologue c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
c'est le weekend profitez bien à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]